can record on this computer and we are now recording it is the fifth I believe of September
can't believe it the time is flying by and then we're going to mute everybody and so that
week everybody could hear okay some questions that we had come in in this last week
or about the rife machine so one question that somebody asked on the Facebook group about the
rife machine good questions that I think their questions that were applied to everybody because
they could pertain to everybody and we do share when you're in for the two day or at your home
visit we encourage you to use your rife machine other than your cancer programs or your line programs
because it comes with about two thousand other programs out there and it just seems like a waste
if it's not being used in a way that can help you your family members your loved ones your friends
we have I have one patient that lives a couple hours north of our us that had a cancer whose patient
started with us on eight years ago I think he's doing fantastic he uses his as a ministerial most
in chairs it with people it is church to come over and people that he meets he's very outgoing
gregarious personality great guy just loves people and he and he has people come over and do the
rife machine and he could talk with them and develop a relationship with them and it's really can
be a blessing you're never going to burn the thing out so the one I use at home I think is about
seven eight years old it's the original bulb on it and I've never moved a fuse never never
moved a transistor and we use it every single night unless we're going on vacation or something with
just a very frequent name so how would you use it if you're not using it for cancer so for instance
we run ours on cancer programs every night but we have run other programs as well so if we have a
cold or flu oncoming we'll run cold and flu programs or cold and flu oncoming programs viral programs
viral complex one of my favorite I've shared is the accelerated healing program it is our initial go-to
with for any health conditions as equal to nutritional go-to for us in our house I have we have my wife
and I have five children three of whom are out and other owned with families two of those have a
wife at home one by a second oldest is a daughter who's also a doctor she has a wife at home she
homeschools her five children at home and they just use it occasionally so they're not using it
every night they're not running necessarily night programs but they she runs it on the kids whatever
they're they're coming down with something or she's not feeling well or husbands not feeling well so
they use it just as kind of their medicine just to go to for different things typically like colds
and flu and viruses and things like that that's that's typically the only problems that they have
because they eat really well she's very into natural healing she is a chiropractor she adjusts them
all the time they just don't have a lot of health issues by next oldest is a is by son and they
use that rife at home for the same situations if somebody's coming down with something he had it
it is 20s had shiggles a few years ago read the shiggles program for a while in really really
bad case of shiggles but they they got their rife initially oh gosh their son is now just turning
seven turning eight I think sorry I have 16 grandkids turn to keep them all straight sometimes
but their second oldest I think is turning eight and at 14 months he was diagnosed with retinoblastoma
which is a cancer in the eye but that's what they first got their rife and their little guy uses that
every night on a program that I've created for them but they'll steal that out of his room an occasion
they use it whatever they have other issues with themselves or any of the kids so how do you use it
you know shit my kids get you know let's say if you have cancer you're using your rife but
you have other children outside of your home would it be a good addition a good gift maybe a good
something to encourage them to invest in to use it home I would say absolutely
it's not again a magic one for every disease but it certainly as it go too we have so many
testimonies of how ready it with other programs could be so beneficial with so many different health
conditions I just can't even begin to comment on the positive effects of using a rife machine
at the heartiness of it as far as its durability is really second to done if any of you
bedded by office in the last four months ago I purchased a different radio frequency rife machine
from a different company just to test it because I myself proclaimed her and I like to test and try
different pieces of equipment all the time so I've never ever satisfied them because they tried to
look at what's out there on the market is there something better for my patients out there
and though I like this one that I have in my office it is so fiticky it's just a pain
there's no way I would ever sell it to anybody do I need it in my office no I should probably sell it
and get rid of it but I couldn't bring myself to sell it because the true rife is a better
value it's actually less expensive and it's just 10 times the machine so that would that one would
be my fifth fifth different rife device that I've owned so I understand when I started
in street cancer patients 20 years ago we did not use the true rife and I don't even I don't think
existed then we used a a beam ray and a light beam generator and that's how we operated and
tell true rife came to be and I think it was eight nine 10 years ago we started using the true rife
and boy it's just been a game changer for us it's just it's just 10 times the piece of equipment
of any of its competitor so there's just really nothing like it on the market for that for cost
for durability for programmability for ease of patient use and for power and benefit and the
amount of programs that are available it's it's just there's just second there's just not anything
that's even in the same category and no I don't own any part of true rife's
company nor do I make any money of machines that Mike sells so Mike is the owner of true rife he's a
great guy that's another reason why I like the company because you have to have good service whatever
you buy something to me that's important if you purchase something and then this there is service
that's needed and it's poor it's very discouraging Mike just of course I'd probably his biggest
purchaser of his machines because he's he's so good to me but he's so good to any of our patients
if you say that you bought the machine from us he typically turned around time is same day turned
around and where else you're gonna get that and I can't tell you I've done most costly repair we've
ever had on a machine was $150 and I had a patient this was years ago call and said the machines
don't work he we walked him through a bunch of different possible fixes no no no not that I said we'll
set it back to us he was about four or five hours away mailed it back to us and the entire top of the
machine was melted out I kid you not it looked like he put the thing in the oven already something
because this whole plastic case seat of it was melted down about an inch and I thought oh my gosh
he didn't even mention that to us that's kind of funny so we sent it back to Mike and he called me
laugh he said he's only seen this once before the motherboard inside the machine heated up
that he said the only time he's ever seen that before is if somebody read it on bath for over a week
rather programs instead of it being on a bulb or did not have the bulb plugged in so the bulb wasn't
plugged in at least two outlets here the electricity it's high frequencies coming out of here the
electricity arc and just heated up the motherboard and it melted the plastic of the machine all the
way down and that was $150 fixed he had to put a whole new case and cleaned it up and stuff so
um you know maybe somebody else's had a more expensive fix on a machine if you really damaged it
or you know drop kicked it across the limit room for some reason but to my knowledge nobody's ever
told me that we used to have repairs on the bulb and the cords these actually these cords right here
the solder used to come loose but that was years ago and we used to he used a lighter cord
um uh and we have not had that problem for a couple years um sometimes you'll get these bulbs
burning out actually that's a blessing what that happens uh if I created these I would not have
these bulbs on here at all they light up the room too much at night um this is showing a handheld
ground which we don't even use but um otherwise it's just a great machine uh to use it for all sorts
of different problems copulate it with nutrition copulate it with diet is always best
but use it alone for different conditions for animals um I've had multiple doctors call me
with uh pets with cancer that want to be the program a machine for their dog they're both dogs
um for uh their dog's cancer and they had really good success with it uh so it's a great tool I have
numerous patients that have more than one at home and um it's a great tool to have at home so
we'd highly encourage you to encourage your family members to get one other question says uh
Dr. Cutters commented this was last week a comment about working out and not to work out so hard
that's your out of breath let's talk a little bit about that so is it good for a person with cancer
so that's what we're talking about is it good for a person with cancer to work out aerobically
meaning that aerobic workout is that you're using a lot of oxygen in the workout so it's a
high demand of oxygen in the workout um so runny would be an example of that so runny especially
doing training here's a marathon or this guy is obviously at his end point of aerobic workout here
um either that or he fell down or something I just pulled this up to the internet so I know
though the story of this but is it good to do aerobic working where you're really really sucking
oxygen uh for use of muscles so let's talk about that so in order to talk about that we need to look
at this famous chart that I've showed you dozens and dozens of times this is the pathway
that you make ATP a deadacene triphosphate which is your fuel source for muscle use it's energy
so in order to make energy you take food you break it down into glucose it goes through glycolysis
which there's multiple steps here and one glucose molecule makes two pyruvate molecules
and then it has some choices here it you want it to go into this way through the pdh gene
to make to turn into acetylcoids mA actually two pyruvate turn into two acetylcoids mA here goes
into the cramp cycle and makes a lot of energy so when you're working out this is going this way
matter of fact the definition of being in shape is is literally how fast you convert pyruvate
to acetylcoids mA so when you go out and start working out you haven't worked out for five years and
you're going to go for a walk oh my gosh i walked a mile and i was really tired um your ability to
convert pyruvate into acetylcoids mA is quite limited so when you go and you walk
a mile and you're really tired and your legs are getting sore you're not converted
pyruvate into acetylcoids mA very well so that it's shunting pyruvate down this pathway
in your producing lactate or lactic acid lactic acids whole purpose is to fatigue you
so the purpose of lactic acid is to make you sore so you stop working out well it does make a
sense why would you do that because pyruvate is an intermediate metamilite and like many
intermediate metamilites meeting pyruvate itself has no endpoint purpose in your body pyruvate
is poisonous so if you have pyruvate sitting in your muscles because it's not getting converted
to acetylcoids mA you'll start damaging muscle tissue and cell walls so you convert pyruvate
into lactic acid and lactic acid makes you sore makes you fatigued and you go oh i got to stop
i got to rest and i'll live for another day to work out and tomorrow you go work out again
and you go another mile and then the next week you're going to buy a little half of the next week
you're going two miles and this process through the pdhgd is converting pyruvate to acetylcoids
mA more efficiently and the more efficient you become or i should say your mitochondrial your cell
cytoplasm because this piece is taking place of the cytoplasm or the gel of the cell or the
this piece is taking place in the mitochondria so the more the more efficient your cells are becoming
and converting pyruvate to acetylcoids mA you are effectively quote unquote giddyed in shape so
that's what giddyed in shape is the more in shape you are the more you can work out so that's good
for us right yes it is it is very good for us so we want to be able to convert pyruvate to acetylcoids mA
is efficiently as possible problem is is that if you entered your world of cancer with a cancer
diagnosis and you're not really effective at converting pyruvate to acetylcoids mA then we don't want
to get that we don't want to we don't want to push this pathway well we do want this pathway to work
well but the problem is like i said in the process of getting it to work well you're going to produce
a whole bunch of lactic acid and lactic acid is a fuel source for cancer this is right here
this pathway is called the warburg effect you've heard of auto warburg on a warburger the 1930s
discovered that many cancers are fed from lactic acid or lactate and that's why this
diagram here says increase excess lactate or lactic acid can lead to an alcoholic liver disease
diabetes hyper cholesterol ebia issues and cancer and it could be a major fuel source for cancer
so should a person well let's i was in really good shape before i had a diagnosis of cancer so
can i kids can i still work out really hard no you can't so you can work out but you don't want to
work out to the point where you're really fatigued and you are producing any sortus because that
sortus is lactic acid so well good as things i'm just walking the myelin i'm sore okay well i understand
we do want to exercise when we have cancer because we want to get oxygen into the tissues and
increase circulation of oxygen because remember what i said an oxygenated tumor is a happy tumor
meeting it's happy it's gonna stay by itself and it's not gonna do anything it's not gonna grow okay
so when you oxygenate a cancer you're going to cease its growth but when we are going to work out
and work out really hard we're stealing oxygen from the cancer but that's not good because it's
gonna grow faster and we're producing excess lactic acid which is gonna feed the cancer so by recommendation
for cancer patients can cancer patients still work out let's let's put people into categories
what if i'm in really good shape i'm in really good shape but i really used to work it out
well just chill it out just a little bit so you stay below the baking yourself sore and depleted
oxygen so workout in a way that gives you joy and it's not like fatigued you out so that you're like
heavy breathing oh my gosh that was a really good workout if you're used to working out and you are
used to getting a joy out of producing endorphins and endocampalins at a point where you are very
fatigued and you're in a deep breathing and you're sucking oxygen and you've kind of been trained
that that's really joyful because you really got a good workout on this so this is really beneficial
but you also have produced a lot of lactic acid and you've stole oxygen from your cancer site
so we don't want to do that so just chill out a little bit back off a little bit on that exercise
routine enjoy your exercise routine maybe do some biky where you coast a little bit more you enjoy the
scenery and you're going fast you're opening up your boats you're getting a lot of oxygen and you're
just slowing down a little bit and you're listening to your body and you're not pushing it
category two is people that never really been working out I guess I haven't been that exercise
hasn't been a real priority in my life should I start exercising well those people should only exercise
nice and chill go out for a walk enjoy your time smell the roses do something you like go shoot some
baskets play a little tennis but not to the point where you're going to get really sore just do it
up to enjoy it it's very hard to be super specific with with that without talking to each
one of you individually question came in it says are you say lactic acid feeds cancer
but the dot cause cancer yes I am saying that lactic acid does not cause cancer but does every
human being have some cancer cells in their body yes does that mean that nobody should work out
hard because they have cancer cells in their body I'm not saying that so if you don't have an
diagnosis of cancer you have no hint of having cancer there's no chance that you're you know we
have a lot of kids are growing in your body there's nothing wrong with working out hard and trading for
the exposted marathon so does being sedentary create excess lactic acid a really good question
the answer is no however the more sedentary it individual is the less this gene is working
and the less this gene has actually had to quote unquote work out then that conversion
from pyruvate to acetylquids that is even slower and this is taking place in this individual so if
person is a couch potato never works out is allergic to exercise are they producing lactic acid
because they have to get up and walk or they have to go do things yeah that's not good either so
that's that that's that teeter totter balance that we're talking about we want to exercise we want
to get oxygen to our tissues and circulate blood around our body but we don't want to like okay
no i'm gonna get it in shape it it'd be stupid and work out too hard um and this is this is most
commonly a problem of people that were athletes in school people like me who used to run and used to be
pretty good and pretty fast honestly to me for me to go running later in years though
it's downright depressing okay when you used to run a 10k or a 5k at 16 minutes and 30 seconds
and now i'd be lucky if i make 32 minutes that's just downright depressing if you do what a good time
so it's um it's uh so then people like me tend to push it and think that i'm still a high school
student and end up producing a whole enormous amount of lactic acid and that's not good it's the
other group that i'm talking to are people that tend to be kind of addicted to working out and um
that's the people you know who you are and it's one of the people who asked this question
is would be this category and it really takes it gets a lot of joy out of being really in good shape
but what it doing so you might want to back off a little bit because we don't want to produce a lot
of lactic acid so it's heavy that balance we don't want to be so sedentary at a coach potato
that this gets no workout and anything we do produce since lactic acid because it goes down this pathway
that we don't want to push this pathway so hard so that's the balance that we have
second question came in about organic uh mattresses do i know of any organic
mattresses that would be good i found this picture of the internet of an organic mattress i don't
know if it qualifies to exactly what the person was talking about but i do think it is organic
i have some of these out in the barn if you want some because we are using road bales for the horses
though and the square bales are taking up space so you just call me and i have a bunch of square
bales for you and i will get them off to you sorry just kidding but organic mattresses are a great
choice um if we had to buy another bed um which we bought one of them a years ago that's not an organic
mattress and we're not up for buying another mattress i would consider it the problem is they're really
pricey um i think they have come down what at least when we looked at them about four or five years ago
they were like really expensive um and we opted against it uh for a couple of reasons just
partly because um the ones we tested were comfortable but i think there's so many more on the market
and so much more competition and demand for it that the the prices have come down and the quality is
going way up i do i did hear of a patient that bought a mattress topper so it was like uh it was it
goes on top of an existing mattress and it was only like four inches thicker three inches thick
and it was a topper so the whole idea of of buying an organic mattress is that think of the chemicals
that are in the foam um in that uh that are in your bed and you're sleeping on those all the time and
I'm sure they're leeching um into our environment we're breathing those in um if you put a mattress
pad on an organic mattress um pad and organic sheets maybe you're not getting them through that
but there is some of that that's taking place i don't know how much we have to everything we do if
we're to kind of put a balance i mean you got if you're not you don't have organic fluoride and
organic carpeted and organic paint on the walls you're getting chemicals leeching from your environment
all the time as it is um however going with maybe an organic mattress pad or an organic mattress
topper i did see that those were far cheaper and you're not sleeping on the foam you're sleeping on
the the content or the organic content i think there may not have so that seemed like uh that seemed
like a really good uh way to go and if it was if you you know the problem is you spend a lot of money
on a bed and if and if three months you hate the thing and you're going to back ache all the time
waking up and you go well what's worse um the possible chemicals in the mattress or be having to go to
the car after three times a week to deal with my back problem and not getting a good night's sleep and
you know the dangers of not getting good night's sleep has all sorts of inherent issues with cancer
and all sorts of diseases so we certainly don't want that to take place so you got to be comfortable
we actually have a select comfort bed and i have a lot of issues with select comfort beds
because i'm sleeping basically plastic um and uh we have uh one that they have the a few years ago
they came out with uh these other certain pads that go over it so there's no mold issues because
i know a number of years ago the select comfort beds had mold issues they've remedied that problem
we regularly check ours for mold so there's we there it's always perfectly clean and dry
um the the issues that we have is that my wife likes her bed very soft and i like my very hard so we
could never be happy on a regular mattress um we also have uh topper uh uh it's not a big foam topper
but it's an organic mattress pad um that covers it and then we have my wife buys organic sheets
so um we're we're really happy with our mattress for the most part um so but um that's always an issue
you you'd hate to invest a bunch of money and something and then not get a good night's sleep but you
it's hard to give it back i know i've seen a television a lot of these new
mattresses that come in a box that you just order on the internet did you they open them up and they
they fluff open well those are all a full-based petroleum type product it's like boy that can't be good
so i would be cautious of those things but um uh uh and i don't know maybe people on this
forum have had a good experiences with them but that's a great question that would be a great question
for the facebook page too so if you guys have a mattress that you like if you could please post it
on the facebook page i think that would be a real help to a lot of people then you could have
kind of a query of questions back and forth on that i think that would be helpful to a lot of people
because that's a great question all right i am in a little bit of a time crunch so i have time for
maybe a couple questions so i will open it up to hold on a second i have to um unmute everybody here
okay you are unmuted i got time for a couple questions what about the cord on the right
should it not touch your body or cross under your head or the cord the cord these cords that go to the
ball yeah the heavy cord um yeah there's times that i'm wake up and i'm laying on the cord um i don't
know that it's a big issue um there is frequencies there's electricity coming through though so it's
best not to have be laying on the cords um i know mike at your wife says sometimes the core if the
cords have are crossed and tangled it could cause issues i we haven't really had that happen with the
new cords that he had that he came up with the new ones that that was an issue when he used a
thinner gauge wire um i don't really had an issue in the last few years i'm just trying to keep
him straight um and try not to lay on them um we have ours we don't currently but we just have
ours go the the machine was underneath our bed and then the computer was on my bed stand and then the
cords from underneath our bed came up behind our bed and we have a um headboard but it came up between
the headboard and the mattress and then the bulb laid the weed us so um then it was we're never touching
the cord i have the bulb a little bit more towards my body then and have switched around a few different
ways to get comfortable um doctor comes would you be surprised if um i said like when i touch my
headboard which is metal i get old yeah you will so if you touch metal while especially if the bulb
is real close to you you will get a little you'll get a little um jolt if you like on my on my cell phone
uh i i have a couple metal pieces to it if i touch those metal pieces i can feel the frequencies
going through them but it's typically only at certain frequencies um it's not at all
frequencies but absolutely if you have a metal headboard and you touch it you will feel a shock
absolutely yeah i do thank you tells you that it's working doesn't it
uh
doctor conners uh huh um this is Lisa um so how i know the closer the bulb is the better but like you
saying you had it on your headboard um like but we don't have it on our headboard it comes up
underneath our headboard and it lies it was lying right next to us so um you want it you want it
close to you so if you're if um so if you are if you are in a state where your cancer is at a good
state of remission and your husband is wanting to get some therapy too if it was 12 inches away from
you and 12 inches away from your husband that's fine 18 inches two feet away from each of you
you're both getting adequate treatment if you're in the middle of of a more of a serious state of
your cancer you want to be stuggling with that thing okay doctor conners this is Donna from
Margaritao uh huh um last week i spoke to you about some uh blood work that i had done and i sent
to your office i just wondered if you had received it um i will have to look again um if you would do
me a favor and call the critic you could actually i think those everybody will be here for another hour
um call and set up a time that we could talk um so i'll everybody to grab that out of the email
get our search for that it will talk about that okay all right i have a praise um my uh multiple my
loma went from um two point nine to two point five wow and that that was good um all my
is going in the correct direction um i'm still a little bit concerned about the calcium level being
okay that's right i didn't remember see it at the calcium level let's talk about that
yes okay but i just want to praise the lord for that
he's good yes yes thank you go for directing this in that pathway oh sure
and i'll call the clinic okay thank you um doctor conners this is Sharon i was just wondering if
maybe my expectations are too high but earlier this year i was really in really bad shape like i thought i
was um doomed and they put me on a new medication chemo oil chemo and i started improving to a point where my
tumor markers went down to like 62 which would like lower than they even started with
and with the rife machine and then i'm using medical marijuana and i'm doing you know some health
things i just figured well i got to jumpstart from the medication and now the rife machine and everything
else will kind of carry me through but within now this month it's already turning and it's going
in the wrong direction and i just so discouraged okay well we need to talk because if they just go
in the wrong direction that's typically the cancer is like all right we're gonna we're gonna change
how we're be how change how we're being fed so we might need to do a 180 on your diet we need to tweak
your your um nutrition so i don't know exactly i don't remember what you're on but let's pretend you're
medicinal mushrooms for for the nutritional people therapy you could say um it could now become
a meal to that so we we could do distance kinesiology and test to see what's going to be the best
approach so call again make sure you call right when you hang up here it's at a time where we can talk
and that going so don't get discouraged it's just this is the way cancer is it's just always trying
to stay alive and you just have to stay attuned to it and go okay well i'm gonna change course here
and tweak some things and get back on the the wedding path here well i have to admit that i'm not doing
you know perfect with with all the nutrition because i i'm so nauseated and um it's hard to
sometimes stomach some of the things that i'm supposed to be eating you know it's just really hard
well that's okay if we have everyone it says if you go back to your binder that first page on
diet that i wrote it says this is a diet not a religion so don't beat yourself up and don't don't
don't be looking to cast blame on yourself or anybody or anything it just is what it is we live in a
fallen world and we just gotta these are just little motivating factors to go okay what do i need to do
to get back on the boat here to see what i need to do don't don't do that to yourself but don't let
the enemy put those thoughts in your head just go okay what do i need to do to get other wedding
side here yeah i can see why people you know don't want to take chemo because it does ruin a lot of
other things for your your health and it gets you off track with with other things but it's i'm scared
to take it i'm scared not to take it you know i understand i understand but that's okay that's okay
so everybody's got to make a personal decision with that and we are a grace-based clinic and we know
that that is a personal decision this is not a alternative clinic that you're a bad person if you
choose chemo i might choose chemo i might not choose chemo and i may lead a person to do chemo that
has nothing to do with their cancer maybe it's i've said this a hundred times maybe god's
gonna lead a person to do chemo for for other reasons maybe to witness to a chemo nurse maybe to encounter
somebody walking in the hospital i don't know you just got to do what you feel like you're supposed to
do and don't listen to anybody give you any grief about that so um your purpose in life is just
to be obedient and trust that god has the answer to regardless of which way it goes so
buy a goal for you is just to tweak things if we need to tweak things so that's the next step
okay thanks that's your conner yes uh this is Liz and michigan
peppermint works for me when i nauseated but they you gave me wonderful advice when i took chemo
the fasting that got rid of the nausea and the diarrhea that was the best advice yeah that
that fasting that uh sheet that video that i put out on you know things to do if you're doing
what you're doing chemo um it's really we got a lot of feedback on that that it's really really helped
um and it wasn't by great idea that i came up with it was um uh the oncology clinic in california that
is doing fasting mimicky diet and and at a 24 hour fast prior to chemo um that was working with
the university of southern california and doing a research program and it's it was just really really
good results so that's where we got that from good short work for me i had i had the first chemo i
didn't you know i came by with all these snacks and drinks and everything oh it was a nightmare the next
time when i dealt with you you told me fasting and i fasted in the day before and the day of taking chemo
i wasn't even hungry till about three o'clock the next day afterwards but it worked and i
applied it worked oh what's different for me is i'm on daily chemo oral chemo right now so you know what
helps also it's it's shared if you're experiencing a lot of nausea are you or is it one of the issues
nausea one of the things helps with me is um the diGs so Liz is talking about um the spirited peppermint
oils i believe and um yeah also you could use ginger shoes yeah i actually use fresh ginger and make
like a tea out of it there's uh there's an essential oil from young livid it's a mix it's called
diGs i think di g i z something like that and um it's supposed to help with digestion but it has
ginger in it and it has peppermint and spirited it and several other things in it and it's a
oral one it's one that it's a it's vitality brand so it's meant to take just orally straight
um and i use that oh i that really is good so that's a great product too my daughter gave me a gel
capsule that was peppermint that worked uh where'd she get that um she's in her um so let me listen
see if i can find the name of the bottle and find it here um it's called it's it's heathers
and it's peppermint oil um capsules with ginger and phantol okay and you just swallow that
yeah right and actually it says irritable bowel syndrome but i just took a capsule when i was nauseated
once and it worked we have to look on on amazon or something to see if they sell them there
heathers thank you thank you members okay yeah
Dr. Connor this is Deb from Ohio um i just got some of the fantastic mimicking diet
and um i have a lot of gas and also the tumor on my well actually it's a lymph node that's
the con tumor but anyway it has kind of shrunk but then around it it's it's gotten softer
is that a good sign or not yeah that's a very good sign you always want to tumor to get softer
so being a dentist around it is okay yep so make sure you're drinking enough water and as far as
your gas goes that has to do with the lack of digestive enzymes and just make sure i know you have
digestive enzymes make sure you're taking that with your food so that your don't have carbohydrates
just sitting in your gut for emptying okay one more thing um oh shoot oh gout all i was on the fat thing
mimicking diet my my thumbs started hurting me like it was gouty is that
something to be concerned about um it could be most likely it's it's probably heavy metals
in your joints that are coming out oh so the sauna yeah yep yes okay one more thing about the
mattress covers we i got jannises.com has um bearer cloth that you put over your mattresses so they
don't outgas on you what is that called it's called the barrier B-A-R-R-I-R.
a bearer cloth yeah and you can put it over your mattresses i made a sack out of mine and put a zip
on it, and it's 100% cotton doesn't leak out anything. Wow, that's interesting. That's cool. Okay.
Yeah, that's great. Okay. Thank you. Yes. All right. Well, we are going to call it for the day.
Oh, excuse me, call it for the night. Maybe Deb and other people that had ideas on that mattress
that were good. You might want to post them on Facebook too for others who won't get through this.
And I'll get this up on the Facebook page. Thanks so much, everybody.
Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you.
Thank you. All right. Bye-bye. Bye.